[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin
ja was wichtig ist und wichtig wird wir
fassen es in den nächsten minuten wieder
für sie zusammen und damit ihnen allen
einen schönen guten abend und mit mir im
studio für den sports wieder kristin
otto sehr gerne gut na ja und das sind
heute einige der nachrichten themen des
tages
die ampel parteien drücken aufs tempo
bis freitag soll entschieden sein opfer
sondierungen echte
koalitionsverhandlungen werden
in deutschland gibt es zu wenig
ladesäulen für elektroautos das
bundeskartellamt fordert jetzt mehr
wettbewerb
und vier tore gegen nord mazedonien
sicher in deutschland das ticket zur
fußball wm in katar
ja was macht die regierungs findung
nachdem gestern schon zehn und am
vormittag ungefähr vier stunden beraten
wurde haben spd grüne und fdp heute
zarte einblicke in die
sondierungsverhandlungen gewährt die
kunst der beteiligten weiterhin im
ungefähren bleiben und dabei aber
trotzdem optimismus verbreiten wem das
vielleicht besser gelingt als anderen
erfahren wir von patricia wiedemeier
aufmunterung nervennahrung was auch
immer am morgen gab es von greenpeace
erstmals schokoriegel für alle
mehr als zehn stunden hatten sie am
vortag zusammen gesessen heute morgen
gleich wieder beim anschließenden
pressebriefing wurde von spd und grünen
viel optimismus verbreitet wir haben
einen guten auftakt für die sondierung
gehabt das waren intensive gespräche das
waren gespräche bei denen alle
relevanten themen angesprochen wurden
wir haben uns gemeinsam auf den weg
gemacht die menge an gemeinsamkeiten ist
größer geworden die mégane unterschieden
ist kleiner geworden aber es bleiben
auch noch sachen zu lösen zu klären alle
relevanten themen wie digitalisierung
moderner staat klimaschutz europa sie
seien besprochen worden konkreter wurde
es nicht die fdp gibt sich zurückhaltend
waren vor hürden auf dem weiteren weg
gemeint ist unter anderem das thema
finanzen das ist ein sehr ernsthafter
und schwieriger sondierungs prozess aber
das heißt nicht dass wir nicht sehr gute
gespräche miteinander führen die
gespräche ich kann das nur betonen haben
einen sehr guten ton und haben auch eine
sehr große seriosität und sachlichkeit
die stunde der wahrheit stehen nun bevor
so volker wissing am freitag soll es
wohl eine entscheidung geben ob es zu
koalitionsgesprächen kommt bis dahin
beraten sie in kleineren runden weiter
olaf scholz ist nicht dabei er ist auf
dem weg in die usa zum g 20
finanzministertreffen
fragen wir noch mal nach bei theo koll
in berlin theo also spd und grüne
scheinen guter hoffnung bei der fdp weiß
man es nicht so genau wonach sich das
jetzt für sie aus also die verteilung
von guter hoffnung und zurückhaltung
entspricht ungefähr den politischen
mehrheitsverhältnissen in diesen ampel
runden denn da steht die fdp in vielen
fragen er allein gegen spd und grüne
daher auch glaube ich die mahnung des
fdp-generalsekretärs eine vereinbarung
gelte erst dann wenn alles vereinbart
zeigt und dennoch stehen die chancen
eher gut denn witzigen hat langjährige
ampel erfahrung aus rheinland-pfalz fdp
und grüne haben übrigens weitgehend
unbeachtet in den vergangenen jahren
viele verbindungen in der opposition
alle verhandler haben die erfahrung des
scheiterns von 2017 noch im hinterkopf
und der zustand der union macht die
alternative eine jamaika koalition ja
immer unrealistischer auch das
diszipliniert die drei unterhändler
müssen die bisherigen gespräche jetzt
sind einen gemeinsamen text gießen und
freitag bis wir dann vielleicht mehr
vielen dank für die einordnung nach
berlin theo koll ja jetzt geht's um
parteienfinanzen und deutschlands
höchstes gericht das
bundesverfassungsgericht in karlsruhe
verhandelt heute und morgen eine
spannende frage dürfen die parteien sich
selbst ihre zuschüsse vom staat
aufstocken
2018 ist das geschehen damals hatte die
groko ja im bundestag beschlossen alle
parteien bekommen mehr geld konkret pro
jahr zusammen 25 millionen euro mehr die
obergrenze für die jährliche
finanzspritze wurde damit auf 190
millionen aufgestockt die opposition die
lief sturm dagegen sprach von willkür
und zog nach karlsruhe sarah tacke
berichtet
karlsruhe messehalle damit mit genügend
abstand gemäß der korona vorschriften
verhandelt werden kann ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht hierhin
umgezogen wir wollen die richterinnen
und richter heute und morgen klären ob
die große koalition in dieser abstimmung
2018 die obergrenze für den staatlichen
zuschuss der parteienfinanzierung
anheben dürfte fdp linke und grüne
meinen nein es gab ein verfahren bei dem
schlichter greift nicht hinreichend
dargelegt wurde warum diese erhöhung
nötig ist wieso jetzt auf einmal dieser
hohen geldbedarf nötig ist da hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht enge grenzen
gezogen zu recht um eben zu verhindern
dass der eindruck entsteht die politiker
würden sich hier einfach selbst bedienen
keine selbstbedienung sondern zwingend
notwendig sei die erhöhung so die
verteidigung
die digitalisierung hat dazu geführt
dass die parteien enorme aufwendungen
tätigen müssen um die sozialen medien zu
bespielen sie müssen sich schützen gegen
hacker angriffe und sie müssen permanent
reagieren auf die diskussion die im
internet stattfinden wie viel zuschuss
eine partei vom staat bekommt richtet
sich zum einen nach den wahlergebnissen
zum anderen nach den mitgliedsbeiträgen
und auch die spenden von privatpersonen
werden bis zu einer höhe von 3300 euro
berücksichtigt je mehr also mitglieder
und spender der partei überweisen desto
mehr gibt der staat auch dazu mit wie
viel geld darf der staat parteien
maximal unterstützen ohne dass der
eindruck entsteht parteien würden sich
selbst bedienen das ist die kernfrage
die die richterinnen und richter hier am
bundesverfassungsgericht verhandeln
dafür müssen sie nun unter anderem
klären ob es etwa einer unabhängigen
expertenkommission bedarf die errechnet
wie sich der finanzbedarf der parteien
entwickelt
um sehr viel geld geht es auch in
frankreich dort nimmt präsident makro 30
milliarden euro an steuergeldern in die
hand um der industrie zu helfen
voranbringen soll das erneuerbare
energien aber auch die atomkraft bei uns
ein auslaufmodell bei unseren nachbarn
immens wichtig 56 reaktoren sind in
betrieb sie liefern 67 prozent des
stroms das problem ist allerdings die
reaktoren sind im schnitt 36 jahre alt
und darum setzt frankreich auf neue
meiler darunter sogenannte mini
reaktoren thomas walde berichtet
emanuel makros programm für frankreich
2030 lässt keinen zweifel an seinen
ambitionen
erneuerungen in wichtigen technologien
und industrien soll in frankreich
souveränität sichern dazu setzt man auch
auf atomkraft
wir müssen die produktion elle
unabhängigkeit wieder errichten in
frankreich und europa erstes ziel bis
2030 entwickeln wir neuartige kleine
atomreaktoren die weniger müll
produzieren
eine milliarde euro will macau
investieren denn so genannte mini
reaktoren wie sie bislang china und
russland entwickeln auf schiffen etwa
während die sicherheit solcher reaktoren
in anderen ländern angezweifelt wird
gibt es ein halbes jahr vor der
präsidentschaftswahl in frankreich einen
wahren wettlauf zur atomkraft
nur wo es gibt diese neuen kleineren
reaktoren iw entwickeln sollten wenn die
franzosen hier ihr vertrauen aussprechen
im kommenden jahr werde ich die
entscheidung für dieses programm treffen
die loxxess logo programm auch
erneuerbare energien sollen ausgebaut
werden windkraft hat derzeit nur einen
anteil von sechs prozent am
französischen energiemix doch sie stößt
vielfach auf widerstand selbst
französische grüne wollen darum nicht
sofort auf atomkraft verzichten
wenn ihr grüner in verantwortung kommen
werden wir bestimmt nicht alle reaktoren
sofort ab 2022 vom netz nehmen einfach
zwei drittel wandel obwohl frankreich
mit alten anlagen wiederholt probleme
hatte setzt sich die regierung auf
europäischer ebene dafür ein atomkraft
als grüne energie anzuerkennen sie sieht
sich darin durch steigende energiepreise
bestätigt
hilfsorganisationen schlagen schon
länger alarm in afghanistan hat
mittlerweile jeder dritte nicht mehr
genug zu essen die welt müsse handeln
warnte heute auch un-generalsekretär ich
bei einem virtuellen gipfel der g20
staaten die eu will insgesamt eine
milliarde euro bereitstellen seit august
herrschen in kabul er wieder die
radikalen islamisten der taliban viele
banken sind geschlossen in
krankenhäusern fehlt es an allem allein
zehn millionen kinder brauchen jetzt
dringend hilfe alltag in afghanistan
heißt für viele ums überleben zu kämpfen
katrin eigendorf sie haben nur eine
hoffnung heute nicht mit leeren händen
nach hause zu kommen einen job zu finden
auf einer baustelle als träger
irgendetwas wenigstens für einen tag
verrät kann man gar war büroangestellter
jetzt ist er tagelöhner es ist jetzt
schon spät nach 37 kriegst du kaum noch
einen job hier gibt es leute die seit
einem monat keinen job mehr finden
konnten verzweiflung und not das bild in
den straßen von kabul wo familienväter
versuchen ihr hab und gut zu verkaufen
mit der machtübernahme der taliban ist
die wirtschaft kollabiert die meisten
unternehmer ins ausland geflohen die
zahl der kinder die betteln bis
dramatisch gestiegen 80 prozent aller
familien leiden hunger hat kann man gar
hat noch eine wohnung für seine frau und
die drei kinder
doch die essensvorräte sind minimal es
gibt trockenes brot zucker und tee außer
dass ich bin bereit einen teil meines
körpers zu verkaufen zum beispiel eine
niere um meine familie wenigstens eine
zeitlang ernähren
seitdem die taliban die macht übernommen
haben sehen sie keine zukunft mehr für
melap ist es bitter dass die schulen für
mädchen geschlossen wurden
mein vater hat alles versucht dass wir
eine gute ausbildung für die zukunft in
unserem land bekommen jetzt ist die
situation sehr hart mein vater und meine
mutter können nichts mehr für und thun
afghanistan droht eine hungerkatastrophe
ohne internationale hilfe doch dafür
werden die taliban den geberländern
zugeständnisse machen müssen
im frühjahr diesen jahres da gab es
viele neidvolle blicke nach
großbritannien weil es mit dem impfen
viel schneller vorangehen als bei uns
aber zur wahrheit gehört auch dass in
europa die briten in sachen kronor mit
am schlimmsten betroffen waren und wer
trägt dafür die verantwortung ein
parlamentsbericht lässt daran keine
zweifel
boris johnson und seine regierung
andreas stamm berichtet aus london der
beginn der pandemie immense
herausforderung und eines der größten
versagen im gesundheitswesen jemals mit
tausenden toten als folgen so der report
des britischen parlaments über die
korona politik der regierung der
zahlreiche versäumnisse auflistet egal
ob lockdown oder masken pflicht immer
wurde zu spät reagiert erfolgreiche
ansätze der pandemie bekämpfung
andernorts wurden ignoriert
so brauchten wir drei anstatt nur ein
lockdown was auch daran lag dass es bis
mai dauerte um ein test und
nachverfolgung system aufzubauen es
wurden drei entscheidende monate
vergeudet
vor allem katastrophal dass ältere ohne
tests aus kliniken in altenheime verlegt
wurden um den kollaps des krankenhaus
systems zu vermeiden die führenden
verfasser parteifreunde der bericht ein
schlag ins gesicht der premier im urlaub
sein sprachrohr gelassen
als johnson hat schon im mai erklärt
dass die regierung für alles was
passiert ist die verantwortung trägt und
hat sich für das entstandene leid
entschuldigt
ein weiteres beispiel für teflon borries
so beobachter dem eine mehrheit der
wähler alles durchgehen lasse auch wegen
des erfolgreichen impfprogramms dass der
bericht positiv hervorhebt vor allem
deshalb wurden ende juli fast alle
corona beschränkungen aufgehoben doch
das virus feiert weiter mit konstant 30
bis 40 1009 fiktionen täglich sowie etwa
100 tote die lage des gesundheitssystems
bleibt angespannt dazu drohe eine
grippewelle aus den wenigen daten die
wir haben deutlich dass eine parallele
infektion von grippe und corona das
risiko zu sterben oder schwer zu
erkranken deutlich erhöht
manche regeln wie etwa die masken
pflicht zu experten habe man
leichtfertig aufgegeben denn die
unsicherheit wie sich die
gesundheitslage entwickelt sei groß fast
so wie zu beginn der pandemie
vielleicht überlegen sie sich auch ein
elektroauto anzuschaffen oder haben
bereits 1 wer schon 1 fährt weiß allzu
große auswahl beim auflagen gibt es noch
nicht tatsächlich schauen sie mal
existieren in deutschland derzeit nur
rund
47.000 öffentliche ladepunkte dabei sind
inzwischen mehr als eine halbe million
reine e autos zugelassen fast genauso
viele hybride kommen hinzu die
ladepunkte sind außerdem ungleich
verteilt am dichtesten in hamburg bayern
und baden württemberg württemberg am
dünnsten in mecklenburg vorpommern das
bundeskartellamt fordert jetzt mehr
wettbewerb beim ladestrom isabel de la
vega
e autos boomen der ökostromanbieter
lichtblick würde gern wie viele andere
unternehmen die öffentlichen ladesäulen
mit strom beliefern doch hier in hamburg
geht das nicht wie fast überall in
deutschland gehören die lade sollen
mehrheitlich den stadtwerken und die
wollen ihren eigenen strom verkaufen im
moment geht der besitz der ladesäulen
ein herr mit der stromlieferung an
ladesäulen und das wäre so als wenn sie
in ihrem haushalt nur den lokalen
stromanbieter wählen könnten und nicht
wechseln könnten und so ist es im moment
an der ladesäule bei den ladesäulen
existiert in deutschland statt
wettbewerb marktkonzentration
allein in den zehn größten städten
werden 62 prozent aller öffentlichen
ladepunkten vom jeweils größten anbieter
betrieben das bundeskartellamt
kritisiert dass uns ist wichtig dass
öffentliche flächen für alle betreiber
zugänglich werden und dass es hier keine
bevorzugung beispielsweise von
stadtwerken gibt damit wir hinter
möglichst viele betreiber haben mit der
folge dass die autofahrer möglichst
große auswahl haben wenn sie eine
ladesäule anfangen denn konkurrenz
belebt das geschäft die ladesäulen
preise aber sind mitunter hoch und
schwert so durchschauen besonders für
die die unterwegs spontan bei einem
anderen anbieter laden wollen steht
eigentlich erstmal für das stunde
mindestens da und gucken welche app
jetzt dafür zuständig ist muss sich neu
registrieren die anmeldung bestätigen
zahlungen hinterlegen also es nicht wie
es überall gezeigt wird einfach
schneller anstecken und gut ist
lichtblick möchte klagen wenn sich der
markt nicht ändern sollte hin zu mehr
transparenz und wettbewerb
erst ein andauernder vulkanausbruch und
dann noch mehrere erdbeben zum
katastrophengebiet auf der kanaren insel
la palma der 1200 grad heiße lava strom
der frist sich dort immer tiefer in wohn
und industriegebiete hinein und zwingt
noch mehr menschen zur flucht christel
haas
riesige steinblöcke schwimmen auf dem
lavastrom manche so hoch wie ein
mehrstöckiges haus es sind wohl die
trümmer der abgebrochenen vulkan
nordflanke
es hört nicht auf im gegenteil die
ausbrüche sind heftiger geworden
weiter bergabwärts herrscht hektik sie
laden alles ein was sie tragen können
vor ein paar stunden hatte es alarm
gegeben etwa 700 einwohner müssen
innerhalb weniger stunden ihre häuser
verlassen die lava droht sie zu
verschlingen
die lava kommt wir müssen alles retten
bevor sie das
ich packe die sachen von meiner tante
bevor dieser teufel kommt denn die lava
bahnt sich ihren weg genau auf ihr haus
zug und auf das meiner familie
ganz in der nähe hat die feuerwalze
bereits ein industriegebiet samt
zementfabrik vernichtet schon jetzt sind
1200 häuser zerstört dazu hunderte
hektar land
und jetzt noch zu einer meldung mit
happy end die vermisste achtjährige
julia ist wieder da seit vorgestern war
das mädchen aus berlin verschwunden
während eines wanderausflug es im
grenzgebiet zwischen bayern und
tschechien hatten ihre eltern sie aus
den augen verloren rund 1400
einsatzkräfte machten sich auf die suche
heute wurde julia dann endlich gefunden
unterkühlt aber sonst wohlauf und
christin auch beim sport geht es mit
guten nachrichten weiter überall viel
freude 40 in nord mazedonien der fünfte
sieg im fünften spiel unter hansi flick
dadurch hat sich die deutsche
fußball-nationalmannschaft neben dem
gesetzten gastgeber katar als erstes
team weltweit vorzeitig für die wm
endrunde 2022 qualifiziert eine
überzeugende leistung und perfekte
punkteausbeute unter hansi flick alle
treffer fielen in der zweiten hälfte der
zuletzt unglücklich agierende timo
werner der in den letzten wochen viel
kritik einstecken musste mit einem
doppelpack der neustart der dfb auswahl
ist geglückt
ich bin sehr stolz das ergebnis braucht
man jetzt auch in der gruppe nicht
überbewerten aber wir haben schon die
dinge sehr schnell umgesetzt das was
haben sie flick auch fordert für den 14
0 endstand sorgte der erst 18 jährige
jamal musealer mit seinem premierentor
im nationalteam auch die junge
generation überzeugt unter flick spielen
sie wieder erfolgreichen fußball einen
traum start für den neuen bundestrainer
tja kein traumstart aber erleichterung
bei stefan kunz als neuer
nationaltrainer der türkei nach dem
unentschieden zum einstieg konnte mit
dem 2 1 sieg in lettland die chance auf
das wm ticket vor den letzten beiden
spielen gewahrt werden
tennisprofi angelique kerber bleibt als
letzte deutsche spielerin weiter auf
erfolgskurs beim wta turnier in indian
wells die 33 jährige erkämpfte sich in
der kalifornischen wüste zum vierten mal
nacheinander den achtelfinal einzug die
erleichterung am ende riesig dabei ist
der erste satz eine klare angelegenheit
für angelique kerber zwei breaks und ein
schnelles 6 2 gegen die russin daria
kassab china im zweiten satz hart kerber
aber wie so oft verliert den faden und
den satz 1 zu 6 im dritten folgt dann
ein break nach dem nächsten am ende
jedoch findet die 33 jährige deutsche in
ihrer spur zurück gewinnt den satz mit 6
4 und trifft im achtelfinale auf die
australierin meiler vom netz
und das heute nacht um 3 uhr dann zum
schluss noch die frage an dich christine
beatles oder stones beatles es ist gut
zu wissen dann weiß ich dass jetzt auch
wer ist die bessere die coolere
erfolgreichere band bedeutender für die
musikgeschichte ist ja eine frage die es
fast so alt wie die beiden bands selbst
und er hat jetzt seine antwort gegeben
paul mccartney bezeichnete die stones
und mick jagger wenig schmeichelhaft
einen blues coverband und fügt hinzu ich
glaube unser anspruch war ein anderer
[Musik]
aha also merken meint also die beatles
werden dann doch ein bisschen
bedeutender gewesen i can't get no
satisfaction ist ja einer der
berühmtesten stones songs und wer jetzt
heute mein persönlicher wetter kommentar
aber mal schauen wie es weitergeht
erfahren sie gleich von katja honnefer
claus kleber begrüßt sie später um 21
uhr 45 im heute journal wir sagen dann
jetzt goodbye und morgen gerne wieder
helau um 7 schöndienst vergangen
[Musik]